big news this week elon musk just
announced that he's building a 1 billion
plant in austin to add 5 000 new jobs to
the city and the state of texas
this was announced recently uh here's an
article from cnbc saying elon musk chose
freedoms
texas offers for new tesla factory
state's
gop governor which is governor abbott
let me tell you why this is so important
and a very big difference between a
person like elon musk
saying no to california with the
challenges he was having
where he was getting shut down to say
you cannot open your plant
and he comes and he says i'm opening up
my plan because i believe i'm essential
and then he chooses texas why is this so
important for everybody that's living in
california
and everywhere else here's why let me
give you an example of what happened
in 2016-2017 in 2016-2017
carl icahn legendary billionaire
left new york to move his
office and his business to florida
why because that's just he's going to
save money on taxes this is because
new york is way too high then leon
cooperman which many of you probably
have never heard of
he had a feud with massachusetts senator
elizabeth warren and he also left jersey
to go to florida and david tepper who
probably you've never heard of
also another billionaire hedge fund
billionaire left jersey forward florida
and paul tudor jones ii which you've
probably never heard of who's a
billionaire worth 5.1 billion dollars
left connecticut to florida and eddie
lampert probably somebody you haven't
heard of left connecticut to florida in
and barry stern lake left connecticut to
florida in 2016. now why am i keep
saying you probably haven't heard of you
probably haven't heard of you probably
haven't heard of
the point i'm trying to make to use the
following point here see joe rogan was
just asked yesterday by
uh uh as joe i believe joe the son i
asked him uh uh
oh watch this are you moving i'm out of
here
when do you leave soon texas or yeah i
wanna go to texas
i gotta i'm moving to texas so now let
me get this straight
joe rogan announces he's going to texas
this guy runs a number one podcast okay
he's moving to texas
elon musk announces he's building a
billion dollar plant
in texas and tells california you're
annoying to deal with but i'm still
going to stay with you a little bit but
long-term plans
i'm looking at texas what is the biggest
difference between a joe rogan saying
he's moving to texas between
elon musk saying he's moving to texas
and all these billionaires carl icahn
leon cooper man david tepper paul tudor
jones
eddie lambert barry sterling what is the
difference between these two guys saying
they're moving in the other names you
ready here's why
when i moved to the states we moved to
glendale california
if you know anything about glendale
california armenians are
all over glendale california why when
you look at the assyrian community it's
a very small community i'm half our
meeting half assyrian
many assyrians live either in detroit or
they live in torlak
san jose northern california why when
you look at a lot of
persians they live near santa monica and
beverly hills
why you can go look at italians
they live in new york you can go look at
irish daily
why though we gotta ask that critical
question of why here's why
this is how it works armenians didn't
want just when they just wake up and say
glendale's got the perfect climate for
us to move to assyrians didn't just say
torlak's the place to go to because it's
the perfect place
for a syrian so let's go to detroit
that's what we're gonna italians
new york's the place for us let's go to
new york cubans we got
the moment an influential person who's
got a big
mouthpiece leaves everybody follows
let me say this one more time when the
first influential armenian moved to
glendale
everybody else said our men moved to
glendale we're all moving to glendale
who were coming from iran who were
coming from russia who were coming from
lebanon it doesn't matter
because of an influential person left to
glendale we're going to
because an influential italian move to
new york we're going to
because you can go look at haitians
italians
irish mexicans puerto ricans it doesn't
matter
there's a massive puerto rican community
in orlando why orlando because an
influential one went first
if california doesn't get their act
together
when a mouthpiece like elon musk
or a mouthpiece like joe roaching with
the level of influence that they have
here's elon musk's twitter account let
me just show this to you he's got 37.1
million followers
when he sends a tweet he gets 590
000 likes when he sends a tweet people
follow what this man is saying
when you got that kind of an influence
and you say no
to texas and you go to a different place
guess what happens
other people listen and that
gradually leads to an exodus if
california doesn't get their act
together and think
just because the weather is so great
people are eventually going to be naive
enough to stay and here's the thing
don't get me wrong california and
governor newsome and garcetti and all
these other guys
you're going to keep the people that are
tied because they're family you're going
to keep the people that are emotion
connected to the people there
you're going to keep the people that are
just kind of like you know what i'm okay
it's not terrible but i figured out
you're gonna get the people that have
been sabotaged to think it's the best
place to be
but you're gonna lose your critical
thinkers and job creators and
mouthpieces eventually
and then one day you're gonna wake up
and say i thought you guys loved the
beach i thought you loved the weather
here what happened
and people gonna say wait a minute if i
look at the u.s map
and i look at what the us map offers to
me you know
i can definitely go if i want i can
definitely go
let me see some of these places i can go
to florida
they don't offer any taxes i can go to
i can go to a different place i can go
to nevada i can go to
tennessee they don't offer any taxes in
tennessee
and tennessee's coming up what if i go
to a great city like nashville
what if what if i go to fort lauderdale
what if i go to orlando what if i go to
tampa
that's coming up didn't brady just go
there what if i go to houston what if i
go to austin what if i go to san antonio
what if i go to nevada what if i go to
some of these places
and gradually this beautiful state that
i love
live 24 years in that state is going to
take a hit
so will new york so will illinois if
they don't realize
that you cannot push your business
owners your job creators
and your influencers out when tiger
woods the
tiger woods decided to move his family
to jupiter and live in a florida jupiter
it's a nice little island i was there
last week
when they decide to move it's not a big
deal why because tiger doesn't go out
there sharing his opinion and saying
what people ought to be doing
but when an elon musk that is not afraid
of telling people his opinion
or when a joe rogan who runs a number
one podcast goes out there doesn't move
like that you better believe a lot of
people are going to sit there saying
babe did you hear about it
did you hear about it babe i did maybe
it's time for us
what do you think i don't know babe i
think it's going to make a lot of sense
maybe you ought to be thinking about it
so yes this is a very
big news of elon musk deciding to build
a billion dollar plant
in austin because it is a statement
that's being made on how
california handled the pandemic and how
they treated their business owners
and they're eventually going to push the
job creators the creative people to say
i just can't do it here anymore and
we're starting to see a glimpse of it
with elon musk